I mean face facts are facts that this is
all in your head are you telling me that
I'm still in Tahiti no Colson I'm
telling you that you've never been to
Tahiti or Malta or Puerto Rico or outer
space or the framework or the future
you're on the table Coulson
code blue you're going to lose my it's
in your nature I'm locked out here not
an option it's okay boss this was never
gonna work they didn't have something
mr. stark said anything he needs
no no no no I've been through too much
I'm not gonna let this nightmare get hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my agents of shield 100th episode video
obviously spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there were a bunch of Secrets
that they revealed if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos between
this Infinity Ward Deadpool the Deadpool
TV series it is going to blow up in the
next couple of months that Avengers
twist that I put at the beginning of
this is really just the beginning of it
there were a couple big payoffs he was
mostly intended to be a love letter to
the fans and if you watch my DC TV
videos arrow had its hundredth episode
last year during the big crossover event
they almost had the exact same premise
it's like it's a wonderful life is like
the go-to thing to do for TV shows in
their hundredth episodes this is what
things could have been like so the
really big stuff though I know you're
asking questions about them talking
about Tony Stark like mr. stark says
anything he needs does that mean the
Tony Stark knows that Coulson is still
alive
these weren't Phil Coulson's jacket I
guess he never did get you to sign them
short answer is no because this was all
happening in his head in the basement he
was just imagining these things the
president of Marvel TV Jeph Loeb did say
that they would address that at some
point like the Avengers would learn
about Coulson in some way we don't know
exactly how they're gonna pull that off
but the TV show does have a plan for
that
they're back in present-day infinity
Wars spinning up so there's all these
opportunities later in the season
remember this is episode 12 there are 22
episodes in the entire season so there's
still plenty of time for them to rope in
Avengers stuff so don't worry about that
too much right now we don't know exactly
which episode is gonna be airing when
infinity war drops in theaters but it'll
wind up being really close to the finale
but the whole reason why all this crazy
stuff was coming back lash hive and
Deathlok was because it was manifesting
their fear so their fear was making
these things real and it was because
they kept the three monoliths next to
each other that's also the reason why
the earth kept blowing apart so quake
did not quake the earth apart it was
this rift in space-time caused by the
three monoliths so logically taking the
next step the reason why they kept going
through the time loops is because they
would not let Coulson go down there
himself somebody else
go down they wouldn't be able to solve
the problem or they die or they would
step into the light like that's what
this version of Mike was trying to get
him to do his mind space Mike come into
the light like step into this alternate
dimension where things are different
they did their Fitzsimmons wedding I
mean it was a nice moment we knew that
they were gonna do it eventually and
when they were talking about the
hundredth episode and Jeph Loeb was
teasing the idea that a wedding is
something that you do during a TV shows
100th episode it was like okay it was a
pretty foregone conclusion that it was
gonna be Fitzsimmons even though Mae and
Colson sort of have this romance thing
going between them and he's slowly dying
I'll address the ghostwriter part of
this too because that gets into his deal
but as part of the Fitzsimmons wedding
they revealed that deke is really their
grandson like he says oh you don't have
this ring it belonged to my mom or my
grandma or something like that so
turning the timeline is just more likely
that he's their grandson remember his
father was killed by one of the other
people in the future he probably looked
a lot like Fitz and Simmons which is why
we didn't see him otherwise it would
have been like hey wait a minute
you look just like me and kind of like
Simmons - what's going on here but again
because it's only like the middle of the
season they'll probably figure that out
by the end like they'll have their
little family moment like isn't this
weird we're talking to our grandson
who's been helping us out this whole
time so they get all dr. Hui with time
travel getting into the ghostwriter
stuff
Coulson revealed that when he took the
riders spirit into him it burned through
all of the Tahiti things that were
keeping him alive so all that Kree
technology is gone now so when we see
all this blackness that looks like it's
infecting him it's really just his body
going back to being dead slowly so he's
slowly reverting back to pre Tahiti
Coulson remember he died they brought
him back to life so he's just going back
to being dead he didn't make a deal to
become a writer in the future which is
what I originally thought that the deal
was going to be like oh he'd become the
writer eventually
so depending on how hopeful you are they
will find a way to save him by the end
of the season even though all the
characters got some really good moments
during the episode this was really Clark
Greg's episode like he can sell just
about anything probably the most
fantastic actor on the show the plot was
a little underwhelming I did expect it
to be a little bit bigger but that was
also kind of the way I felt about arrows
hundredth episode - like oh this is what
they did you know like I kind of
expected it to be much bigger but the
funny thing about Marvel TV in the
Marvel movies is that Marvel movies are
now turning into television episodes
seriously after Avengers 4 there's gonna
be 22 Marvel movies there are 22
episodes of agents of shield in a single
season so we're getting to that point
where you have like hundred and fifty
million dollar episodes of television
that you get on a regular basis every
year so we're almost at the point now
where there's so much movie content like
big huge crazy stuff going on that it
overshadows what's going on on TV
completely whereas that used to not be
the case like we get like maybe one or
two big comic book movies per year so
it's crazy to think that Marvel spends
this much money but just remember that
they're gonna be getting the Fox IP soon
so instead of three Marvel movies per
year technically it will be almost like
five or six Marvel movies per year still
gonna be a while before we find out what
they're gonna do with all those
characters I think Deadpool for the most
part will be left to his own devices
because that franchise is just so
successful they don't want to mess with
that that's just lazy writing but the
general is still on their tail and she's
starting to put the pieces together the
Deek is from the future because he
shares DNA with Fitz and Simmons but
because her daughter is the one that's
leading their version of the
Thunderbolts
they'll probably chase them down that'll
be this last arc of the season so you
have shield versus the new Thunderbolts
and dove Cameron said that her
characters weapon the one that cut yoyos
arms off he's actually made of vibranium
although it doesn't light up like the
ones you saw in Wakanda I think for the
most part her character's gonna be one
of those people that senses that her
mother the general is super evil and
helped the shield agents by the end of
the season but because she did the comic
book thing and cut yoyos arms off
they're still
to be some beef between them so let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite part of the episode and how do
you want them to invoke infinity war
stuff later this season like Jeff lobe
said they do have a plan they just
haven't revealed what that's going to be
the showrunners also revealed that
they've written their season 5 finale as
the series finale if the show doesn't
get renewed for season 6 we haven't
really heard anything about that and I
don't think that we will till later this
season so it's probably gonna be several
more weeks before you hear what ABC's
plans are for the TV show but there's a
whole bunch of infinity war that's been
dropping there's some new behind the
scenes that I'll probably post tomorrow
but I have some new Witcher some new
Rick and Morty to post so I'll try to
get that stuff out as fast as possible
but click here for that soul gem promo
breakdown and click here for my video
war preview thank you so much and click
and click here for my infinity war
preview thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]